I use pseudonyms oh yeah pseudonyms
which means fake name
that's what something I only learned
this year one in Scotland if you go for
a shy you go for a Joby that's what
that's what it means some one of them I
use as Anita Joby
and the other one is uh
I think I meant to keep them Secrets
but I think when you look at me
you you think suck a fat one
but these are these are actual credits
on songs now yeah yeah there's one by
kygo and Dean Lewis it came out that one
actually did well so actually I've just
it's called them all done to know them
uh no can I did very well and an easy
job he wrote that one yeah yeah I took a
fat one's yet to have any cut spot
I'm feeling it